you
[Music]
let's get started so our next session
section will be introduction to CKS
young soo is the author of that paper
and he's the s and welcome Yoon su and
this is this is not something like a
lunch talk it would be more technical
and I think you should pay attention to
that thank you thank you very for the
introduction hi everyone good afternoon
I give a brief tutorial on ZK case and
which is one of two who movie encryption
schemes supported by the Microsoft C
library and please feel free to
interrupt if you have any questions any
time so so eighty technic technology
basically brings the plain computation
to the encrypted word so most of our
mercy encryption schemes including PGP
or pf3 support discrete computation as
explained in previous session such as
boolean arithmetic or integer arithmetic
or modulo P model of P operations but in
practice we also use some other variable
types such as double to take some
advantages of approximate computation
and the psychic has natively support
encrypted approximate arithmetic so
basically this scheme was designed in
2017 and back then it was initially
called Han by the authors but nowadays
it is formally called secure case after
the author's name to distinguish the
name of this scheme from the name of
public libraries which implemented this
the same scheme so there has been a
sequence of researches improving the
functionality and efficiency of this CKK
scheme and I give some high-level idea
about algorithms and API over the
library in the Sakai case mode so that
you can play with it later without
checking order details of these papers
and the primary core of this talk would
be to understand the this example quote
in the C library you can
if you have installed the C library then
you can just open this GB file if you
want this code basically evaluate or
cubic polynomials and multiple real
numbers and another goal is to learn
some important concepts and language is
widely used in each community so that
you can use this keyword during the
bootcamp discussions so before we get
started let me first record the floating
point and fixed point arithmetic because
it's sometimes confusing so in the
floating point number system a real
number is represented by a product of an
integer called significant and scaling
factor which is usually represented as
base to the power of a base and the
intuition behind this representation is
that the floating point number is not
exactly the true value we want to store
but it's just approximate value which
implicitly includes some numerical error
after the radix point of this
significant and there are too many
method for multiplication between two
for two floating point numbers they are
called floating point arithmetic and
fixed point arithmetic they are somewhat
similar but both of them first multiply
two significant pitch and make perform
some rounding operation to make
trade-off between precision and
efficiency but the main difference is
that in the case of floating point
arithmetic we already store or fixed
number of repeats of significant and
scaling vector can dynamically change
during the computation as you see in
this example our floating point numbers
have six bits of a significant but in
the case of a fixed point arithmetic we
keeps the same scaling factor not the
bit size of a significant so that the
bit size of significant may change here
the imp
have six feet but the output
significance is seven bits integer but
scaling factor is table as a two to the
five so in the case of encrypted
computation the fixed point arithmetic
is more suitable since we are not able
to check the bit size of intermediate
values during the computation so
floating point arithmetic is much more
tricky so roughly speaking sketches
suppose a sort of fixed point arithmetic
but with some extra noise from the
system so in this top message and plain
text we leave her to two different
variable types so message would be a
vector of floating point numbers or a
vector of complex numbers and it should
be first transformed into a plaintext
via a public including map before being
encrypted and the ckk scheme provides
various homomorphic operations such as
addition multiplication rescale rotation
encoding and decoding our public
transformation between message and
plaintext as noted in previous session
the scheme works over the set of a
polynomial modulo X to the n plus 1 the
set is denoted by r and forgiven message
which is a vector of n over two complex
numbers we first multiply it by a
scaling vector and take these n over two
numbers into a single integral
polynomial using some Lagrangian
interpolation over this ring you don't
have to know all the details but as a to
example if you include this pair of
complex numbers with scaling factor to
27 then we you end up with this integral
polynomial n and we can double check
that if you evaluate two roots of unity
at them then you you recover a kind of
approximate values of 237 times of the
input vectors so
later CKK scheme really supports on
Pereira computation on this multi
priests lot this individual so you can
imagine that our plaintiffs
implicitly has some n over 2 plaintext
slots each of them can store a complex
number and after encoding each of this
lot contains some approximate values of
Delta x zr zi and you should use our
larger data to keep more precision
because M is basically our entire
polynomial so this encoding algorithm
includes on rounding operation so if you
use too small scaling factor then you
lose two most precision significant the
be sort of the radix point okay so in
the source code we first initialize the
IMP vector which is n over two
dimensional vector of real numbers
between zero and one and use encoder
function to encode it into a plaintext
explained and we are going to evaluate
this polynomial so we should also
include the question--the of this
polynomial as well they are PI and point
four and one
it's simply as color so if you include
up high then it is mapped to a plane
test which contains Delta x pi in order
which plaintext close so we can use the
same questions for all slots
okay so are some cute Dino's the residue
ring of our model of shoe which is the
set of integers instead of the integral
polynomial model X to the n plus 1
equations in zmodeler queue so that
secret key Ock case is a polynomial s
and public key or a symmetric key
encryption of a plaintext M is a pair of
polynomial c0 and c1 such that C 0 plus
C 1 s is approximately equal to M modulo
Q so it means that this C 0 plus C 1 as
modulo Q is the decryption turkey dog
sketchiest system so that the decryption
Circuit correctly recovers the plaintext
M if M is smaller than Q otherwise we
will have some modulo Q reduction in M
and the result would be incorrect so for
simplicity we often write as I protect
hypothesis it E is a linear polynomial
c0 plus c1 s and decryption circuit is
just substituting as biologically key
small s so you can just imagine that you
store plaintext blocks and were to plant
explodes in larger black boxes of size
roughly local qubits and only ask a
cyclic owner can open this black box and
the sides of both display paths is
represent parameter parameterize by this
important parameter Q and remember that
this encryption algorithm introduced
some small noise to ensure the security
of HD system so the c0 plus c1 as is not
exactly equal to M but it's just
approximately equal to M so don't know
it different from the Pacific pathways
Kim explained in the previous session in
the case of educators we don't
distinguish noise from plain text no it
is considered as a part of the message
it is just considered to be a numerical
error during approximate computation we
anyway work on approximate numbers with
so matter so if you encrypt the zero and
directly decrypt it then you don't get
zero but just a very small number which
is a known upper bound depending on the
parameter of HD system and encryption
function is in the line 129 in the
source code and the shakyas scheme
supports addition and multiplication
between plaintext and cipher text or
cipher text and cipher texts first of
all the multiplication between plane and
cipher returns the cipher text of the
same website which includes the product
over to this green plaintext loss inside
of way so you can just multiply computer
multiplication between plaintext inside
of this black box and in the case of
ciphertext ciphertext multiplication is
very similar to the previous case but a
bit more complicated because if you
multiply two cybertheft then you get the
same sized black box which include
encrypted product over to plain text and
recorded plaintext or cipher text is
usually written as a DC linear
polynomial so technically you just
simply multiplies to ciphertext and
returns of quadratic polynomial because
it's a product of two linear polynomials
so this homework multiplication is
usually followed by another operation
called linear really linearization which
transform it is quadratic ciphertext
back to the linear stipple test while
almost preserving the encrypted plane
test so the roughly speaking if you
perform the composition of commercial
application and linearization
then it will return a linear ciphertext
which encrypts the product of plenty
lakhs of the two inputs ciphertext so
this is a source code and this procedure
requires some extra public parameter
called linearization key so rescaling is
the key operation which makes CAS have
its own characteristic and benefit
so this rescaling operation works just
like the rounding operational fixed
point arithmetic so after a homo a
multiplication the scaling factor open
encrypted plane test becomes Delta
Square from data so if we repeat
homework multiplication then the scaling
factor will grow exponentially as the
computation progresses and the plain
text will all float the size of display
passed very quickly so similar to the
indicate similar to the case of fixed
point arithmetic the rescaling operation
divide the cipher text by Delta and cut
off the least significant bits log Delta
bits of ciphertext moduli and thereby
plain text so we recover the scaling
factor Delta after rescaling procedure
this is the why the rescaling procedure
is usually comes after whoo morphing
multiplication to Ric to maintain the
same scaling factor during the
competition
so the cipher text modulus can decrease
during the computation by rescaling but
what would happen if we multiply two
type attacks with different module I in
this case there's no good solution of
multiplying two but we just have to
discard some most significant bits over
ciphertext with your larger modulus so
that we make them have same cipher text
modulus before performing model
commercial operation so as you can see
this is not an ideal situation because
we are not fully utilizing the
computational capability over ciphertext
so it is very important to choose the
best circley presentation without this
humble unbalanced multiplication which
we basically waste ciphertext modulus so
let's look at a simple example we just
want to compute a product of four cipher
texts we can consider two different
circuit representation of the same
function if we use the first
representation we basically have three
multiplication but chop them or
unbalanced the multiplication so we
consume log data beat three times so
final size models would be Q divided by
Delta to the third so as you can see in
this figure we could the overflow could
happen if this encrypted Clint X is
larger than the size of this black box
but in other case if we use this tree
structure then we finish the computation
while consuming only to log Delta piece
of cipher text modulus and resulting
cipher text theory has a large enough
modulus for correct description
so I believe you probably got some
intuition why the depths of a circuit is
so important feature in HEA valuation so
the 88 formalized this note 80 community
formalized this notion and came up we
came up with some keywords like a level
cybertek modulus is a product of a base
model of q0 and our power over pay are
based scaling vector data and we say
that a cipher text header level L if
it's epitaxy is modulus is Q sub L which
is product over 2 0 times Delta to the
power of L so this level of ciphertext
is a good indicator which effectively
present computational capability of
cipher text so the if level the level is
decreased by 1 usually after each of the
multiplication and we consume this all a
level and no more arithmetic is all load
when all cipher texts which is the
lowest 0 level so no more multiplication
is allowed for zero level cipher text so
we can use this language to explain the
functionality of ckk cipher ISM easily
so a cipher text is usually labeled with
is level L and scaling vector data and
you can check how a few operations
change this label information of
ciphertext so for example if you perform
rescaling operation on ciphertext then
level is decreased by 1 and the scaling
factor becomes 2 and changes to data
from data Square and as you can expect
the cost of we encrypt the computation
heavily depends on the depth of Homer
fixed system home of the encryption
system so when you bring a computational
task into our encrypted word though
overhead between these plain computation
and encrypt the computation is another
constant
so but it heavily depends on the types
of circuit so in general on optimal
algorithm in computation and number
theory may not be optimal over AC system
so for example when you train machine
learning motor we usually make the use
of gradient descent method but this is
really really expensive in homolytically
encrypted word because we basically
repeat on number of iterations for
updating model and each of iteration
will consume at least one level so if
you repeat 1,000 iterations then you
should prepare a homework encryption
systems operating n is 1,000 level which
is not implementable in practice ok so
let's get back to this example of source
code and focus on the first term pi
times x QP so since it tests degree 4 we
can evaluate this term with only depth
to system by utilizing this tree
structure so we first perform those
killing scaring all the cipher text
followed by linear lies and rescaling
operation to obtain this encryption of X
square with scaling factor Delta and and
then we can use plain cipher
multiplication algorithm followed by
rescaling operation to generate another
encryption of pi times ads with scaling
factor or so theta and finally we can
multiply them to get an encryption of
the first comp desertin so the this is
the source code and we consume the true
level and the most difficult part of
computation is finish it so we should be
almost done but actually the source code
still have more than almost 150 lines
left so in fact what I what I have
explain the 4/4 is slightly different
from the algorithms implemented exactly
implemented in our algorithm because
there has been a bunch of modifications
and improvement of on ck case I will
adjourn for improving its functionality
and efficiency and some of them are not
mathematically beautiful or conceptions
conceptually simple but we na applied
some of those optimization techniques to
our library for engineering
optimizations so I briefly explained
some major issues in implementation over
cks but it's fine if you don't
understand all the details because you
can still enjoy the power of this DK
case library without knowing or thought
it taste so just understanding its
high-level idea is enough so when you
set a parameter for the ckk system as I
explained low Q besides of what these
ciphertexts modulus should be larger
than the product of depth of circuit l
and the bit precision of correctness low
Delta so it could be several hundred or
even larger than one thousand bit in
practice so obviously it is very
challenging to implement this high
precision arithmetic on standard
computer system which because we usually
work on sixty bit 64 bit processor but
this emerging Christian library require
hundred bits arithmetic modulo
arithmetic so Oh
so one well-known solution for this
issue is to use the Chinese remainder
theorem and represent a single module of
pure integer as a to probe integers in a
smaller model I so but we heard that
capital Q was a product of q0 and Delta
to the L which is not compatible with
CRT system so in our library in our
library we searched for a distinct
primes John to date QL and the set of
cybertek's modulus as a product of prod
topic you eyes to support the CRT system
so for arithmetic modulo large ql we
just store to proper small numbers each
of them can be stored in 64 bit you in
64 variable and we can do individual
small water sides operations to
represent large precision arithmetic but
the thing is if we play with this the
chain of cybertek smoothly then the
rescaling operation at level L basically
divides the ciphertext and thereby
plaintext by small Q L naught by Delta
so we can go to only some predetermine
the ciphertext modulus so rescaling
divided we we can't divide ciphertext by
it just on an arbitrary number but some
predetermined primes in the parameter
setting so if we divide ciphertext by
small ql then plant x is also / qø
meaning that scaling factor is not
stable because we started from choice i
Potter with scaling factor data after
multiplication scaling factor becomes
Delta square but if we rescale it
Richard Tisei hotels by QL then scaling
factor becomes Delta square / ql which
is different from theta so this
ciphertext that skill function in our
library which updates so this part this
variable is automatically updated during
the computation we basically keep track
of this scaling vector along the
computation in the case of so in the
case of this example first the inputs
iPod has had a scaling factor to 340 and
after one more education
his scaling factor becomes Delta prime
which is Delta squared divided by two -
and after one more multiplication is
scaling factor would be Delta prime
squared divided by q1 is again different
from Delta prime but the problem is the
second term was point four times X which
require only one depth to evaluate so if
we prepare the encryption of second term
point four times X then we obtain on
encryption 0.4 X with scaling factor
Delta Prime and we show that through
cipher text with different skills Delta
Prime and theta 2 Prime and this is not
trivial
so our simple solution of serving this
issue is just said
scale of our supporters as Delta Pi
manually it is fine because in the
parameter setting excuse me in the
parameter setting when we search for
these intermediate primes from Q 1 to Q
L we try to make them as closest to the
scaling factor Delta so division by QL
is approximately equal to division by
Delta so it's fine to chain set of
scaling vector as data on Delta Prime
and Delta prime to primer slightly
different from Delta but they are almost
close to each other so you will lose
some precision but it's generally fine
and there is another method which
without precision loss you can just
consume one level to change it or scale
over ciphertext but I'm not going to go
into details it's too much and the
precision is another issue when you we
should think about so basic operations
such as multi multiplication were
location introduced on small nodes so we
could say
the bit precision of basic operations or
logo Delta - low noise and the bit size
of noise is usually between 10 to 15
impractical parameter setting so in our
example logo Delta was 40 so we could
say you preserve roughly 25 to 30 bits
of precision observe Redax point when
you encrypt a plaintext or perform some
arithmetic of course in general case
when you evaluate a complex circuit by
representing it as a composition of
basic operations it's generally very
difficult to estimate the accuracy of
Richard you probably need a new vector
analysis to make a good estimation for
precision but it's not just an issue of
encrypted computation even in just plain
computation where you use a double
precision for calculating some
approximate circuit it's not easy to
estimate the precision of Richard so we
have almost the same issue here but of
course you can always increase data to
achieve better precision modulo
switching operation is basically used
during linearization or encryption so
there's a special prime there's an
integer called a special prime which is
denoted by Q I plus 1 and this prime is
enough for a cipher text but this is
reserved for public key or evaluation
keys such as a linearization key so it
this special prime should be larger than
all other Prime's Qi to many is don't
know edge across all operation so I'm
going to skip some details but just
remember that there's just a special
prime which and it is not forced
ciphertext and in this example code the
ring dimension
is to to the certain and for the
security legion loco at plus one should
be bounded by 218 to ensure the security
and since we are evaluating the circuit
of depth - we basically need for crimes
because
qj1 basic base prime Q 0 & 2
intermediate primes Q 1 and Q 2 for
rescaling and the special prime Q 3 for
module of switching technique here
besides over q1 and q2 or our 40 so that
they are approximately equal to the
scaling vector Delta 2 to the 40 + 2 0
is a 60 and q0 is a 60 bit prime so that
we can decrypt the ciphertext correctly
as long as the computation majority is
smaller than 2 to the 20 so message is
always scaled by 2 to the 40 and plain
text should be bounded by 2 to the 60
meaning the exercise of message should
be bounded by 2 to 2 to the 20 but we
are just evaluating a simple polynomial
with more real numbers it's really
definitely bounded by to 320 and finally
the special prime q3 estimate should
have Maximizer or so 60 bit and we can't
object that the besides of our largest
modulus the sum of its size of all small
choice is 200 which is smaller than 218
so this system is secure
I didn't explain this location because
rotation is not necessary for polynomial
valuation but this operation will be
used in some later sessions so suppose
that you want to compute something using
plain text values located in the
different slots in this case you can
utilize this rotation function to
publicly locate the encrypted plane test
and obtain shifted plaintext and compute
some functions on the values in
different plaintext slots and you can
check out this another example code and
this is the last slide and I may as I
mentioned earlier of cipher text has a
final level L and no more computation is
all load when it's level becomes 0 so
bootstrapping is a public algorithm
which generates a high level ciphertext
encrypting the same plain text and you
can do further computation on this
refresh the ciphertext so it's basically
public conversion from level 0
ciphertext to higher level ciphertext we
we can combine this bootstrapping with
the level 80 level d ck system to obtain
a fully homomorphic encryption which
support the evaluation of an arbitrary
circuit with our limitation of which
steps you can just repeat evaluation and
bootstrapping as many as you want
unfortunately this C KS bootstrapping is
not yet available in 0 but we're working
on it so it'll be definitely
released in a later version in the
future hopefully yeah ok thank you for
listening
[Applause]
are there any questions so for the
scaling factor the like bgv rescaling
just like switches switches modulus that
is in the scaling factor I guess this by
restricting the limbs to like be close
to this power of two that kind of like
limits your selection or like your error
grows as the number of limbs grows is
there a way to like get the bgv
rescaling technique to work with this so
technically this rescaling algorithm is
almost same as the modular switching
technique of PGP or pf3 scheme but
purpose is different so in the case of
PGP
you basically use modulo switching
operation to reduce the size of new it
but you just preacher the plaintext up
here this is this rescaling changes the
representation of plaintext so as in
floating point representation so
ciphertext people is killing and after
rescaling are actually two different
encryptions of the same message with
different skill so like
okay
so in this last approximate equality
these two numbers are actually two
different representation of the same
number so we divide this significant by
scaling factor two three five here to
make a trade-off between efficiency and
precision so so since shakyas rescaling
has dysfunctionality the goal of this
kk3 scaling is not too many snow mode
knowing in ciphertext we don't care
about noise because noise is always a
part of plaintiffs we just considered
significant but the significant the side
bit size of significantly increased
after so much education when and we
should cut off it so basically that's
why the ciphertext modular type modulus
chain depends on its related to the
functionality of this rescaling in ck
case so yeah so i would say we are
already using the same technique to
answer your question but the purpose are
different so that's why we have some
additional requirement on his prime so
that's why in the original paper we
couldn't use this ordinance system
because we had to keep this mathematical
simplicity so q was that to be Q 0 times
Delta to the air to keep the same base
but in in later papers we slightly
modified this kim by searching for some
primes approximately equal to theta so
to take advantage of both words in from
engineering optimizations over easily
and still keeping the functionality okay
so for the decryption step so you just
take the like B minus a s mod the cipher
text modulus and then there's no
plaintext modulus that you need to
reduce by is that right yeah that's a
good question so I didn't clearly
explained of what is the plaintext face
of ck case so roughly the plaintiff
space is just our set of any polynomial
but for for correctly decryption the
size of plaintext should be bounded by
ciphertext modules so there is no
plaintext modulus in this scheme you
just work on just our polynomials with
no characteristic yeah but in of course
ciphertext is f has modulus Q so you can
recover plaintext by computing C 0 + G
on s and take modulo skill if you
generate Utah ciphertext correctly then
the result would be much similar thank
you in general okay thank you
to follow up on the decryption so the
plaintext
needs to be smaller than the last q0
right not the full initial big q yeah so
so as computation progresses the
ciphertext modulus decreases and we
don't know how the size of plaintext
will change it depends on emphasize and
circuit but anyway the values should be
already smaller than ciphertext modulus
at low level to ensure the correctness
of evaluation yeah so you're right so
that's why we said 2-0 larger than Delta
because after consuming all levels of
our encryption system you still have a
modulus q0 which is much larger than
Delta so that your message scaled by
Delta would be smaller than Q 0 of
course we we could have overflow could
happen because it also have fun implying
fixed point arithmetic so it is
important to manage the scale of
intermediate values as small as possible
not to I have this overall and another
question on the intermediate Prime's Q 1
to Q L so you set them to be equal to
the size of the initial scale right
approximately yeah is that the best
option or could you also set it in a
different way so
so okay in general you can set any chain
of who model I so because we are going
to anyway keep track of the scaling
factor following the computation but the
thing is as you can see as you could see
in this example of evaluation of cubic
polynomial sorry this is not working
yeah so if you want to add some cipher
text with different skills you should
you may consume one level to perform
someone playing cipher multiplication
and let them have the same scaling
factor so we try to avoid this issue and
stabilize the scaling factors of the
cipher text during computation so that
we can just assign keep almost the same
scaling factor data during the
computation of course I I'm not sure if
there's another better way of saying
parameter but I'll say this is so far
too personal my sort of saving so in the
case of yeah and there are actually more
than one libraries implementing this the
same gkk scheme but they have some minor
differences about these scaling factors
some of them just don't track the
scaling factor but just set the global
scaling factor data while our library
have this variable ciphertext that skill
and updating during the commutation and
edit comment to that in Microsoft CEO
actually we select we generate the prime
numbers to be close to a power of two so
in my example in my talk I show that you
can pass in the bit size of the prime to
set it up
prime prime will be generated with debit
size
I try to get it as close as possible to
two to the power of 40 for example so
you get the best prime available about D
I had two questions about so the scaling
factor first the way to look at it is
you explain fixed point it's 2 to the
power minus whatever is the precision
that's the floating part of it or like
the fixed point
so with these Qi sits effectively you
should interpret as number divided by Q
is the actual value yes so so methods is
the real value you want to increase and
plaintext is just its encoding encoded
message x scaling factor so when you
really recover your message you free
decrypt the cipher text and get a
plaintext and run the decoding function
which include division by a scaling
factor okay so yeah so ciphertext is
basically storing significant parts of
numbers yeah and it also implicitly
stores is scaling later yeah okay
any more questions alright this thank
you for the talk
[Applause]